ART DISCUSSION
OVERVIEW
Evelyn: Let’s see if I can describe this
but George today wasn’t in such a good mood
when we got here and it was very crowded and
he just kinda didn’t wanna go.
And then the minute he started looking at
the art and Carrie pointed things out, he
just, he got so involved in it and started
looking for things himself.
I was just thinking how it brought something
out for him.
It brought something from the inside out for
him – how he was able to get so involved
in it and enjoy it so much.
That is made me realize what a special program
this is.
George: It also makes me more able to interact
with the women or the man at the front discussing
with me.
And it makes me much brighter.
I’m a much more outgoing person…I can
still fumble, I still have a problem with
that, but I can still learn a little bit more
now.
Hello.
I am Laurel Humble
Hi, I'm Meryl Schwartz and we work on The
MoMA Alzheimer's Project within the Department
of Education at The Museum of Modern Art.
Funded by a major grant from MetLife Foundation,
The MoMA Alzheimer's Project allows Meryl
and me and our colleagues in the Department
of Education to develop art discussion and
art-making programs for people with Alzheimer's
disease and their care-partners.
We teach these programs here onsite in the
Museum's galleries and studio spaces, and
also offsite in care facilities around the
city.
Based on our work with this audience, we also
lead training workshops for arts and health
professionals, and have developed educational
resources used by staff of museums, care facilities,
and other community organizations serving
people with dementia and their carepartners.
One of these resources is this video!
This video is for people involved in dementia
care or museum and arts education who want
to learn more about how to facilitate a discussion
about art with people with Alzheimer's disease.
It is designed for individuals with varying
personal and professional expertise, who are
likely working in a variety of settings, each
with their own logistical considerations,
such as spaces, time, and budget.
Accordingly, we've chosen not to focus on
those aspects of programming.
Instead we'll focus on the teaching strategies
and other tools necessary for leading a successful
discussion, including:
Some background information, like general
information on dementia and MoMA's program
structure and approach, and the role of the
educator in creating a successful experience
How you as an educator prepare to facilitate
an art discussion
How to lead a discussion about one work of
art (in depth, going through a series of steps
that prompt a variety of participant response)
And general tips for facilitating your group
conversation, as well as tools for troubleshooting
challenging scenarios
Throughout we'll include program footage and
anecdotes from our experiences.
While our discussion will be framed by our
perspectives as museum educators working with
groups in the galleries, the techniques we
will discuss are applicable to any setting
or situation, so long as you can access and
display artworks or reproductions of artworks.
We encourage you to think of about these programs
as an opportunity for you to learn and grow,
which will inform the decisions you make in
your planning and facilitation.
Throughout we will emphasize the importance
of designing experiences that you, as the
educator, find interesting as well.
In the end we hope that you will feel confident
in your ability to facilitate a meaningful
discussion that leads to new understanding
about works of art and prompts new social
connections amongst participants.
ART DISCUSSION
BACKGROUND INFORMATION
In this section, we'll give you some background
information to consider when planning art
discussion programs for people with Alzheimer's
disease, including what our typical program
structure includes, benefits of engaging with
art in general, basic information about Alzheimer's
disease and other forms of dementia, including
which symptoms we most frequently encounter,
and finally, a general overview of what you
can do as an educator to create a successful
experience.
Let's start with an overview of MoMA's art
discussion programs for individuals with Alzheimer's
disease and their carepartners.
Our programs typically last about an hour
and a half.
In that time an educator leads conversations
about 4-6 works of art that are connected
by a theme.
The educator uses inquiry-based discussion
techniques, that is they ask questions, to
prompt interactions with the works and among
participants.
In addition, our educators share some relevant
art historical information to strengthen the
group's understanding of the works.
The program structure and the teaching techniques
we use are well established in museum education.
In fact, we use them in MoMA's education programs
for people of all ages and abilities.
This is because we recognize that engaging
with art through inquiry and discussion allows
all people the chance to
Articulate opinions and preferences in a space
where there is no one right answer
Explore and exchange ideas with others
Experience intellectual stimulation and come
to new understandings
Reflect on personal experiences and connect
them to world history and events
And finally, to participate in a meaningful
activity that fosters personal growth
These benefits apply no matter who the audience
is, but they are particularly significant
for individuals with Alzheimer's disease who
might be experiencing a dearth of opportunities
for cultural engagement and personal development.
With a diagnosis of Alzheimer's disease there
can be an assumption that people are no longer
able to learn or they won't benefit from exposure
to new experiences.
But surely the desire for personal growth
and development remains and participating
in arts engagement programs can satisfy these
lifelong needs.
>>>
Moreover artwork is particularly well-suited
for engaging people with Alzheimer's disease
because it doesn't move or change.
You can refer to it and talk about it without
relying on short term memory.
Short term memory loss is one of the main
symptoms of Alzheimer's disease, but it isn't
the only one.
We'll talk about some of the symptoms you
may encounter when working with this audience,
but first, let's start with the basics:
Dementia is a general term for a group of
brain disorders.
Alzheimer's disease is the most common form
of dementia.
All types of dementia impair mental functioning
and are severe enough to interfere with usual
activities of daily life.
Dementia may also affect language, visuospatial
functioning and/or executive functioning.
Some of you may already have a great deal
of experience working with people with Alzheimer's
disease or other forms of dementia, while
others may not.
There are a number of resources you can turn
to to find out more, including your local
medical professionals, hospitals or care facilities,
your local Alzheimer's Association, or the
National Institute on Aging's Alzheimer's
Disease Education and Referral Center.
In our experience, symptoms differ from person
to person and many challenging behaviors can
be circumvented through your planning and
facilitation of the experience, as well as
the tone you set as the educator.
Overall, these are the symptoms we've most
frequently encountered in our art discussion
programs for people with early to mid-stage
Alzheimer's disease:
The first is memory loss.
Forgetting recently learned information is
one of the most common symptoms.
Participants may not remember things you or
other participants have said.
We've also encountered difficulty with language.
At times it can be hard to understand a participant's
words and participants may forget words or
make unusual substitutions.
Some participants may have lost significant
verbal ability.
We've also experienced difficulties with visuospatial
thinking.
Some participants may have difficulty navigating
your spaces.
Similarly, they may have difficulty processing
perspective and depth in a work of art.
Another symptom you may encounter is apathy.
Some participants may need prompting to engage
in certain activities.
At the same time, we've seen a lack of inhibition
and impulse control in some participants.
While some may be more inhibited, others may
be candid or unreserved.
In the Tips and Tools section, we'll discuss
ways of addressing some of these behaviors,
if they come up.
Though it is important to familiarize yourself
with the symptoms of Alzheimer's disease and
other forms of dementia, it should not be
your focus during the program.
In fact, in our programs we never mention
Alzheimer's disease.
Our goal is to create an experience where
the presence of the disease is minimized and
people of all abilities are able to engage
and contribute on an equal level.
So in subsequent sections we'll be focusing
mainly on what you can do, as the educator,
to create a successful conversation, one where
all abilities are validated.
But generally speaking, what do successful
educators do?
A successful educator does one or more of
the following at any given point during a
conversation.
First, they model positive behavior for the
group by setting an inviting tone and by treating
all participants as equally valid contributors
They lead the discussion by asking questions
and prompting different ways of engaging with
the work of art
They also sit back and listen when it's appropriate,
at the same time expressing their interest
and enthusiasm in participant's responses
and comments.
They also contribute.
They'll contribute art historical information
and also act as a co-participant sharing their
personal thoughts and opinions from time to
time.
They challenge established ideas about the
work of art, or ideas that the group has generated,
encouraging participants to think larger.
And most importantly, they synthesize all
the ideas that have come up during the discussion
to form one cohesive conversation.
In subsequent sections we'll talk practically
about how to accomplish all these things,
what they look like, and how they feed into
preparation and facilitation.
All in all, the artworks, participants and
you as the educator are all equal factors
in the experience.
Together you contribute to a program that
includes:
Generation and development of ideas
Validation of individual contributions
Socialization among participants
And a general sense of sincerity and enjoyment
It is important to internalize these ideas
as you move forward as they profoundly affect
the experience you create.
ART DISCUSSION
EDUCATOR PREPARATION
In this section we'll discuss how to prepare
to lead an art-discussion program, including:
Choosing a theme
Selecting artworks
Sequencing those artworks
And preparing to lead a conversation about
one specific work from your selection.
So let's begin with choosing a theme.
The theme provides a framework for the overall
discussion and an access point as you introduce
each new work.
You should select a theme that is open and
age-appropriate, and that is of interest to
you.
If you already have works in mind that you'd
like to discuss, then you can build a theme
around them.
Here are some categories of themes that use
traditional reference points from art history.
Focusing on a specific genre, such as landscape
or portraiture, or a movement or time period,
like Pop Art or art from the 1990s, is a straightforward
way of framing your conversation.
You can focus on the work of a specific artist,
or if you are working in a museum or gallery
space, you can investigate a particular exhibition.
But there are also a number of broader ideas
that you can use as a theme, which may be
of interest to you or your participants.
Moving forward, we'll prepare a conversation
with the theme of Family.
Once you have chosen a theme, start to brainstorm
artworks that illustrate that idea.
If you are working in a museum, you may start
by thinking about your own collection, but
if you are working elsewhere you can look
online, in exhibition catalogs or other books,
and so on.
We believe that you can create a positive
and purposeful experience with almost any
work of art, so, as the most general rule
of thumb, choose works that you find interesting,
that you are comfortable speaking about, and
that you think will engage your audience.
With that in mind, narrow your selection to
4 to 6 works of art.
You may not end up discussing all the works
within the time of your program, but it is
better to be prepared with too many works
than not enough.
We've chosen 5 works that relate to our theme
of family -- while they all fit our theme,
each work approaches the idea differently.
The first is Henri Matisse, The Piano Lesson,
from 1916.
This painting shows the artist's son sitting
at the piano in the family's living room.
Next is Family Picture, painted by Mac Beckmann,
from 1920.
It does not depict any one particular family,
but reflects the cultural and economic conditions
families might have experienced at that time.
Our next work is Joan Miro's the Family, from
1924.
While the title of this drawing clearly indicates
a family, the abstract rendering of the various
figures makes for a less straightforward approach
to our theme.
This is Frida Kahlo.
My Grandparents, My Parents, and I (Family
Tree), from 1936.
Which is exactly what the title indicates,
a family tree that depicts the artist, Frida
Kahlo, as a fetus and a young child, with
her parents and grandparents.
The final work is the most recent work, William
Wegman's Family Combinations, from 1972.
The top register includes individual photographs
of Wegman's father, mother, and the artist
himself.
The lower register combines these photographs,
superimposing two images over each other to
create a composite individual.
We've chosen to include Family Picture, by
Max Beckmann, which many find to be a rather
bleak, even depressing scene.
It certainly is not the most uplifting image.
And in fact, we're often asked if we avoid
work that may be considered troubling.
It has been our experience, though, that you
can't always predict how people are going
to react to a work of art.
For instance, in the past I've seen conversations
in front of Rene Magritte's The Menaced Assassin
that have gone smoothly, despite the very
troubling subject matter -- a corpse laying
in the center of the room.
In another instance, I observed a tour wherein
one participant had a very negative emotional
reaction in front of Diego Rivera's Flower
Festival: Feast of Santa Anita, which most
people see as a festive and celebratory work.
Again, it's impossible to anticipate how any
one person will react to a work of art.
Just like the general population, individuals
with Alzheimer's disease come to any given
artwork with their own aesthetic preferences
and life experiences, so it's best not to
limit yourself based on assumptions about
what might be upsetting.
We're also often asked whether or not this
particular audience might have difficulty
processing or appreciating abstract works.
But we have found that this hasn't been an
issue- in fact there can be real benefits
to discussing abstract works.
Accordingly, you can see that on our tour,
we've chosen to include a drawing by Miro,
which is less representational.
Often abstract, or less representational works,
have greater interpretive potential than figurative
works and allow for a greater variety of response,
as there is less pressure to quote "correctly"
identify elements in the work.
Generally, our advice would be to stick with
what feels comfortable to you.
If you're feeling anxious about facilitating
a conversation about a specific work, for
whatever reason, then just don't use it.
Aside from the artwork content, there are
also logistical considerations that might
factor into your artwork selection:
For example, if you will be viewing original
works in a museum or gallery, consider the
work's
Scale - Very small works may be hard for a
group to see.
So in this gallery, it would be difficult
to fit a group around the Gauguin work on
the left.
And even if you could, participants would
likely be distracted by the much larger painting
by Rousseau to the right, so I would not use
the Gauguin, no matter how well it fit into
my theme.
Also, consider how or where the work is installed
- works that are installed salon style may
be difficult to focus on.
So for instance, in this gallery it would
be much easier to talk about the work on the
left as opposed to asking participants to
focus on one work within the wall on the right.
And finally think about the work's location-
works situated by doors, or elevators might
be distracting, and works far away from others
on your tour may be difficult to get to.
The triptych by Max Beckmann, seen here, is
a rich work, but the fact that it's installed
right near the escalators and the main thoroughfare
for accessing the galleries on this floor
make having a conversation there more difficult.
If you are not leading a discussion in a museum
but instead using printed reproductions or
projecting images of artworks, then find high
quality images that retain the original work's
integrity and detail.
The sequence in which you view the works should
offer a helpful way to connect them in the
context of the theme you have chosen.
As a general rule of thumb, it is often better
to begin with works that are simpler or more
straightforward and move to those that are
more complex.
In this same vein, move from more figurative
works to those that are more abstract, or
more abstractly related to your theme.
So for our example, we'll start with Frida
Kahlo's work, which presents a common or familiar
way of organizing a representation of a family.
From there we move to a different image of
multiple family members, though in this case
they are not related to the artist, and may
not have existed at all.
This family is more symbolic of a particular
time and place.
Then we continue on with a Matisse work, which
focuses on just one family member of the artist.
There is an opportunity with this work to
think about the relationship between the artist
and his son.
Our fourth work also includes a few family
members of the artist, as well as the artist
himself, though this is certainly not a traditional
family portrait, as Wegman has created "imaginary"
family members via composites of his and his
parents' faces.
We finish with the least representational
work of the group.
By the time we get to Miro the group will
have had an opportunity to discuss family
roles and relationships as depicted in more
representational images before applying these
ideas to an abstract work.
We've covered how to select a theme and artworks
to discuss, as well as how to sequence those
works.
Next we'll talk about how to prepare for a
conversation about just one of these works
in detail, continuing with Matisse's The Piano
Lesson as an example.
During your preparation, familiarize yourself
with all of the works you've chosen through
a combination of close examination and research.
We'll now go through both of these approaches
in detail, starting with close examination.
Looking closely should be the first thing
that you do when preparing a work.
Eventually you'll be asking participants to
look closely, too, so it's important that
you go through this process as well.
You may be very familiar with the artwork
already or be tempted to do research first
but be sure to dedicate some time upfront
just for looking.
As you look closely at a work, consider its
formal elements, like line, shape, form, and
color.
Notice the work's recognizable elements, that
is, if they are clear, and how they are represented.
Then consider how those elements relate to
each other, including the scale, placement,
and overall composition.
Think about the materials that are used, and
the techniques or processes that are involved
in the work's making.
And finally, consider the work's overall style
or tone.
So let's try this ourselves, using The Piano
Lesson.
Look closely and ask yourself:
What objects or elements do you first notice?
Do you see the three figures?
How do they relate to each other in terms
of location?
How are they different, say in their coloring?
Let's think more specifically about the colors,
both in the figures and overall - are they
bright?
Dull?
Blended?
Uniform?
Natural?
What about some of the other formal elements-
like lines, or shapes?
Do any stand out?
How does it look like this work was made?
Do you think it was painted quickly?
Or did the artist maybe take longer to paint
it?
Does it look finished?
What is your overall impression of the work?
Does that sense come from the colors, the
organization, or from something else?
Now we'll go through this same set of questions,
with Laurel providing her thoughts as she
considers the work.
What objects or elements do you first notice?
I first notice the boy sitting down here,
the woman sitting in the upper right hand
corner, and the big swath of green paint that
takes up so much of the upper left part of
the canvas.
I also notice this figure in the lower left
corner and these random objects atop the pink
surface in the lower right.
Do you see the three figures?
How do they relate to each other in terms
of location?
To me they feel scattered about the canvas.
None of them are overlapping or feel that
connected to each other.
The woman on the right is almost floating
in the air above the boy.
And the other woman is so far from the others,
really wedged into the corner.
How are the figures different, say in their
coloring?
The boy is the most human-like in his coloring.
He looks fleshy, alive.
The one in the lower left is more metallic
color, maybe bronze.
And then the woman in the upper right is mostly
white, with some random patches of colored
paint applied to her.
Their coloring is all very different.
Let's think more specifically about the colors
overall.
There is variety in the colors.
In some places the colors are very bright,
almost unnatural, like the pink and the green.
Other places they are more dull.
I notice how much grey is used in the painting-
that it's in every part.
The placement of the grey seems very deliberate--
usually any other color is touching grey or
black, they're rarely touching each other.
What about some of the other formal elements-
for example the lines, or shapes?
Do any stand out?
I see some variations in line.
There are some very hard, straight lines,
such as the verticals in the center of the
canvas and along the left, and in the woman
in the upper right hand corner.
But elsewhere the lines are more curvy, more
sinewy.
How does it look like this work was made?
Do you think it was painted quickly?
Or did the artist maybe take longer to paint
it?
Does it look finished?
Parts of the work seem unfinished, like the
woman in the upper right hand corner, and
parts of that curvy line work look scratchy.
The boy's face is also not whole.
At the same time, the work seems very meticulously
organized, which makes me think that it might
have taken some time to create.
What is your overall impression of the work?
And does that sense come from the colors,
the organization, or something else?
To me the work feels kind of austere because
there is so little interaction between the
figures, between the various elements of the
work, and between the colors.
Those are just a few thoughts that I had when
looking at the work, and chances are when
you went through, you answered these questions
differently.
Looking closely as you prepare and asking
yourself the same kinds of questions you will
eventually ask your participants should help
you notice details you might have otherwise
missed and also clarify your own understanding
of a work.
Your own observations and interpretations
of a work will guide you when you eventually
facilitate your discussion with participants.
Moreover, based on what you noticed during
the process of looking closely, you can come
to your research with more direction and focus.
For example, I was struck by the color selection
in this work, both the very bright colors
and the use of grey throughout the canvas.
I also noticed the variety of color choices
for the figures, and am curious what that
might mean about them and their role in the
scene.
I'm interested in finding out more about who
these figures could be.
So, again, once you've examined the work,
the next step is to do some research.
Your research will inform your understanding
of the work and help to generate discussion
questions.
Using online resources, exhibition catalogues,
and books, look into the artist's practice
-- what they created over their lifetime,
themes they explored, materials they favored
and how they used them.
Also investigate information about the artist's
life, the time period in which they lived
and worked, and information regarding any
movements or artist groups that they were
affiliated with.
Research information about the work's subject
matter.
Quotations from the artist can inform your
understanding of how and why a work was made,
and quotes from critics, either from the time
the work was made or from later, provide insight
into how the work has been received and interpreted
over time.
Turning again to our example artwork, here
are a few art historical points that relate
to the artist and this work specifically.
Henri Matisse was associated with the Fauves,
or "wild beasts," who were known for their
expressive use of color.
This painting was painted in Matisse's apartment
outside of Paris, as opposed to in his studio.
The boy sitting at the piano in the lower
right-hand corner is the artist's son, Pierre,
who was around 16 years old at the time.
Pierre and his sister, Marguerite, both took
piano lessons as children.
Matisse had two sons and both of them served
in World War I, though their service took
place after this work was completed.
This work includes two other works by Matisse,
a sculpture called Decorative Figure from
1906 in the lower left hand corner and a painting
called Woman on a Highstool from 1914 in the
upper right hand corner.
Matisse often depicted his other works in
his paintings.
And finally, this work exhibits the influence
of a movement called Cubism, through its use
of geometric planes and its flattening of
space.
Of all this information, select a few main
ideas that are relevant to the work and your
theme.
Settling on a limited number of points will
help you avoid lecturing and therefore encourage
a wider range of participation.
So for our example, because our theme is family,
the information about Matisse's family and
their lives is very relevant.
Also the more general points about movements
he was affiliated with or that influenced
him, and the information about his artistic
tendencies, could help inform the group conversation.
Overall, it's important to note that there
will be a difference in how much you as an
educator know about the work, and how much
you'll actually be able to share during the
discussion.
You may do a lot of research about certain
elements of the work, but an opportunity to
share this information may not be organic
to the conversation when the time comes.
We'll talk more about how and when to incorporate
the information you've prepared in the "Leading
A Discussion" section of this video.
In general, when preparing to facilitate a
discussion, keep the following in mind:
Consider logistics.
They may necessarily inform the choices you
make as you conceive of your program
Choose themes and works that you find interesting
and you think will prompt robust conversation
Have your own experience with the work as
you prepare -- look closely and ask yourself
questions
And use your research to increase your familiarity
with the work but select a limited number
of art historical points to share.
All in all this open approach to preparing
your discussion will allow you to prompt conversation
that leads to understanding, without over-determining
participant experience.
ART DISCUSSION
LEADING A DISCUSSION
In this section we'll cover how to lead a
discussion in front of one work of art, structuring
your conversation according to the following
scaffold:
Welcome -- setting up the experience
Observation --looking closely
Description -- objectively describing what
you see
Interpretation -- assigning meaning and making
inferences
Connection -- discovering a greater context
for the work
Using art historical information and
Conversation summary
As we go through this scaffold we'll continue
with our focus on The Piano Lesson, including
clips from conversations that we've lead in
the galleries.
This structure is meant to provide you with
a flexible outline for facilitating your discussion.
It is grounded in prevailing practices in
museum education.
We use it as a guide for structuring our programs
for with people with Alzheimer's disease and
their care partners but also with other Museum
audiences, because it tends to best draw people
out and encourage participation, no matter
their level of ability.
In this section we'll cover how to structure
a discussion in general without focusing too
directly on the specific needs of individuals
with Alzheimer's disease.
Information pertaining specifically to this
audience will be covered in the next section,
Tips and Tools, as will ways of creating a
supportive and validating environment.
The tone you set is just as important as the
scaffold you use to provide structure during
your discussion.
But for now, let's get back to that scaffold,
beginning with welcome.
At the very beginning of the tour and in front
of each new work you discuss, welcome all
participants with a relaxed and inviting tone
and orient or reorient the group to their
surroundings.
Let's take a look at this in the galleries.
Meryl: So I see some of you already looking
at our next work here.
Just to remind everyone, we’re on the 5th
Floor at The Museum of Modern Art, our permanent
painting and sculpture collection.
This is the second work in our tour today,
our theme is family.
You can see that before Meryl shared any information
about the work, she first reoriented the group
as to where they were and how far along in
their tour, and reminded them of the theme.
You also want to take this time to establish
or re-establish the expectations for the discussion
you'll be having.
During your welcome, explain that you'll be
looking at and discussing a limited number
of artworks and that you want to hear from
everyone and that you'll all be building understanding
of a work of art together.
Outline for participants what to expect.
Set a tone that invites comments and other
forms of participation.
Once you've welcomed everyone and made sure
that each participant has an unobstructed
view, allow some time for quiet observation.
Give participants about a minute to just look
closely.
This is their opportunity to focus on the
work and to think of questions or notice particular
areas of interest, which will be incorporated
in the upcoming discussion.
So again, let's look at this in action in
the galleries.
Laurel: So spend a good minute and just notice
the entire thing.
It’s a pretty large work of art.
So look at it from top to bottom, left to
right.
Notice some of the details and we’ll discuss
it together…Notice the colors.
Some of the lines and shapes that are in the
work.
Consider how it is painted and some of the
elements included in the scene.
You can see that Laurel has instructed the
group to look closely, and provided a timeframe
for this observation.
Some participants may not be accustomed to
sitting quietly and looking at one work of
art in depth, so she has also directed their
looking, encouraging the group to take notice
of formal elements like colors, line and shapes.
LH Sometimes, particularly at the first work
of art, I explain why we'll be looking closely
-- saying that often we look at things very
briefly and miss all the rich details of a
work.
I like to emphasize that this is an opportunity
to slow down and appreciate a work more fully.
Next, begin to describe the work.
Description rests upon naming formal elements
and recognizable subject matter.
Asking questions that touch on these elements
will help to create a collective visual inventory
and establish a fundamental understanding
of what is being seen.
Moreover, taking the time to thoroughly describe
the work allows for a wide range of participation
and makes sure all participants are on the
same page before you move onto interpreting
the work.
Let's take a look at this idea in the galleries.
Laurel: So let’s start by describing what
is included in this scene.
What are some of the recognizable objects
that you all notice?
Participant: A woman and a baby.
Laurel: The piano.
And then a woman and a baby.
Where is the woman, Arthur?
Participant: That thing.
Laurel: Up in the right hand corner, we have
a female figure.
And you said a baby.
This thing right here looks like a young person
perhaps?
Participant: It looks like a young male child.
Laurel: Like a young male child, ok.
What else are you all noticing?
Participant: The eyes
Laurel: The eyes on this figure.
Yeah.
How many eyes?
Participant: One!
Laurel: Right!
We have this kind of very legible eye right
here on the left side of the figure and then
the other side is a little harder to make
out, and we’ll get back to that later.
What else do you all notice about this figure
on the right hand side?
Participant: Female furniture.
Laurel: Female furniture!
Bill, how would you describe this figure on
the right side?
Do you think there’s anything peculiar about
her?
Could you tell she was a female figure from
the beginning?
Participant: There’s strips on there.
Laurel: There’s strips on there.
Yeah, she’s stripped down, right?
Participant: I can’t tell if it’s…well,
the look is that it’s incomplete.
Not painted.
I can’t tell from this angle whether that’s
a deliberate omission or whether it’s painted
to look incomplete but in the coloring, in
the outline, it looks incomplete.
You can see that Laurel has first explained
that the group is now going to describe what
they see and she started with a concrete question,
"what are some of the recognizable objects
that you notice" to get them going.
As a general rule, the descriptive questions
you ask should be more concrete, for instance
"What do you notice or see in this painting?"
instead of just "What is going on here?"
In prompting participants to name recognizable
objects the group was able to start identifying
the components of the work, beginning with
whatever jumped out at them first.
Moving forward with the description, Laurel
asked participants to notice many of the formal
elements we introduced during the Educator
Preparation section, as well as the subject
matter and the way in which this work was
painted.
As you lead your discussion, you might not
have time to describe every single aspect
of a work in detail, but be sure to investigate
the entire work before moving on to interpretation.
Indeed, sometimes, participants want to dive
into interpretation right away -- they will
see a work and immediately want to tell you
they think it means.
If participants immediately start to interpret
the work instead of describing it, ask them
which visual clue led them to that idea, or
ask them to connect their comment back to
something they see in the work.
Allow participants to describe freely but
also ask specific questions that guide them
toward elements that you've prepared to discuss
or will ask them to interpret later on in
the discussion.
For example, in that clip we saw of Laurel,
she really focused on getting participants
to describe the boy at the piano, Matisse's
son, Pierre, by asking specific questions
about him.
I knew I eventually wanted the group to think
more interpretively about the boy, as it connected
to our theme of family, so it was important
that we spent a good amount of time just looking
at and describing him first.
Once you feel that the group has thoroughly
described the work, summarize all the elements
mentioned and point out any important details
that might have been missed.
Now you can move onto building interpretation.
Interpretation rests on assigning meaning
to various elements of the work and asking
participants to think about what is merely
suggested and to make inferences accordingly.
There are many ways to prompt interpretive
comments, but a good place to start is to
build off participant's description of the
work by asking them to consider the significance
of what they've seen and described.
In this next clip, Laurel prompts interpretive
comments based on understanding of the color
grey in The Piano Lesson.
Laurel: Suzy is saying that the grey is very
predominate in the painting.
Participant: It looks like, feels like, concrete.
A form of protection, at the same time, the
strength of the facility itself.
Laurel: So, fortification, almost.
Concrete.
Other ideas about this grey and what it might
suggest?
Participant: It accentuates the colors that
were actually used.
Laurel: It accentuates the other colors that
were used.
It really makes them “pop.”
Participant: A deliberate choice.
The entire background is this grey.
For both interior and exterior, he uses the
grey.
And the child’s face, being the only sort
of animate part of the image.
You could see from the clip that participants
were eager to share their thoughts about what
the color grey suggested, but you could also
ask participants to consider other formal
elements of a work, like line, shape or form
in their interpretation.
In that clip, Jordan even speculated as to
why Matisse might have chosen to use the grey
as he did.
You can encourage participants to think of
a work as a series of choices made by the
artist.
Depending on the work, you can ask participants
about the artist's choice of subject matter,
materials, composition, and their overall
style or technique.
During the interpretive portion of your conversation
you can also ask open-ended questions that
touch on what is not clearly visible in the
work but perhaps merely suggested.
Depending on the work, you can ask participants
to make inferences about what time of day
or location might be depicted, or imagine
a narrative for the scene, what could have
happened before or what might happen next.
You can also ask participants questions that
encourage them to think about the work as
a whole.
One way of prompting this is to ask about
overall impression or mood.
Here's an example.
Meryl: So I want to take a step back and consider
the mood or this work overall.
We’ve done a great job investigating some
of these independent pieces but what about
the overall mood?
Carole, do you have a word to describe the
mood of this painting?
Participant: I would say calm or peaceful.
Meryl: Calm or peaceful, that’s great.
Anya, would you agree with Carole – calm
or peaceful?
Participant: Yes, the same word.
Meryl: What’s another word someone would
use to describe the mood?
Participant: I would say somber
Meryl: Somber.
Participant: I mean, even though it’s colorful,
it’s somber, it’s quiet, it’s reflective.
Participant: You know I find it in a way,
happy.
Because of the green.
When I look at the green…I cannot omit the
green and the pink colors.
The salmon color.
Also, when you see a child, playing the piano,
a relaxed woman, and someone who is sitting
there casually, it kinda gives me a feeling
of family.
Meryl: Ted, what’s a word you would use
to describe the feeling or overall mood of
this work?
Participant: The feeling or mood?
Meryl: Yes, what’s one word.
Participant: I would say somber.
Meryl: Somber.
Yeah, what about it to you feels somber?
Or, why do you say that?
Participant: The grey.
And the look on the face of the boy playing
the piano.
He also looks somber.
Meryl: He also looks somber.
Another way of prompting an overall interpretation
of the work is to ask participants to think
of a new title.
Their alternative title may reveal the aspects
of the work that are most important to that
person, or how they think the entire thing
works together.
Here's Laurel doing just that:
Laurel: I mentioned before that title of this
work is “The Piano Lesson,” but if you
had to give it a different title, what would
you title this work?
Participant: At Home.
Laurel: At Home, uh huh.
Participant: Distraction.
Laurel: Distraction!
I like that, too!
Participant: My description would be to call
it The Answer.
And this is the answer – peace and tranquility.
Laurel: The Answer.
Other titles you all would give this work?
Helen, what would you title it?
Participant: Departure.
Laurel: Departure!
And what makes you think of departure?
Moreover, the art historical information you've
gathered during your preparation can also
serve as a jumping-off point for interpretive
questions.
You might ask participants to consider the
work in relation to biographical information
about the artist, the historical and social
context of the work, or the given title.
We'll focus on ways of using the information
you've gathered to generate new threads of
conversation in just a few minutes.
Again, not all of these ideas might be relevant
at every work of art, and certain ideas might
be of greater interest to a particular group,
but this list provides a variety of possibilities
for prompting interpretation.
As participants are interpreting a work, encourage
them to connect what they're seeing to other
objects, ideas, and experiences, thus situating
the work within a broader context.
Let's see this in the galleries
Meryl: This is a work that Matisse made of
his son, doing something that he did all the
time, everyday, in his living room.
So if you were to make a portrait of someone
in your family – 2 questions -- who would
it be?
And what would they be doing?
And maybe turn to the person next to you,
and then we’ll share back, turn to the person
next to you and tell them who you would make
a portrait of in your family, and how you
would depict them, what they would be doing?
Ted, if you had to make a painting of someone
in your family…?
Oh, I see you pointing at Arlene.
And what would Arlene be doing?
Participant: She’d be snoring.
Meryl: Snoring?
So Ted would make a painting of Arlene, who
would be snoring.
But looking beautiful while she did it.
Participant: But I would paint him, reading
and eating.
Meryl: Uh huh.
So Arlene would paint you, Ted, reading and
eating.
Are those two of your favorite things?
Participant: Yes
Meryl: Are those the things she’ll find
you doing all the time?
Participant: Yes
You can see that Meryl has encouraged participants
connect Matisse's work or analyze his choices
through their own personal lens, considering
the people in their own lives.
Prompting participants to connect works to
their own life experiences also encourages
personal exchange among group members, which
makes for a more social experience.
Questions that touch on personal preference,
like, "Do you like this work?
Why or why not?
Would you hang it in your house?" can be applied
to any artwork and are accessible to all.
You can also connect works to other artwork
and developments in art history, but, remember,
if you're asking participants to compare the
work you're viewing to others, be sure that
you have a reproduction or other visual reference
on hand.
Try and reference only what can be seen and
understood by everybody.
While not all of your participants may be
familiar with history, they may have a sense
of world history.
Relating works of art to major cultural changes
and world events provides an additional access
point.
During the course of your discussion you will
introduce the art historical information you've
prepared.
Sharing this information enhances participant
understanding and appreciation of a work and
elevates your conversation.
It can be difficult to determine how much
you want to share about the work you're discussing
-- the information available plus the interest
of your group makes each situation unique.
But as a general rule of thumb, use art history
to validate participants' responses and generate
new threads of conversation.
Let's now take a look at Laurel has used art
historical information to validate participant
response:
Participant: See, I focused on whatever that
is, the candle, but now I see the piano because
I believe the pink is the top of the piano
and now I see one of the legs of the piano
on the left, so it’s coming together but
quite frankly when I first looked at the painting
I didn’t see anything that was that obvious.
Laurel: Yeah, yeah.
It’s not the most legible scene.
Right?
And how many pianos have you seen that have
a pink top like this?
Participant: None!
Laurel: And in fact Matisse was a member of
the Fauves, he was a Fauvist, you might say,
which is a word that translates literally
to “Wild Beast,” but the Fauves were known
for using color in a much more expressionistic
way, not necessarily a realistic way.
You can see that Laurel has picked up on something
that Suzy has already noticed, in this case
the unusual color of the piano top, and both
confirmed and expanded on her observation
by sharing information about Matisse's affiliation
with the Fauves.
This came about organically.
Laurel shared this information at moment when
it was relevant to the conversation
Now here's a look at how you can use art history
to spark a new thread of conversation.
Laurel: So Pierre, Henri Matisse’s son,
was 16 at the time this work was made.
Does anyone else think he looks younger than
16?
Can you place his age?
All: Yes
Laurel: So why do you think Matisse chose
to paint him younger than he was?
Participant: Because he was an artist and
had to be imaginative.
Participant: I think the basic situation,
just looking at the child’s face, I think
the artist was trying to understand the child.
Trying to represent what the child is thinking
or feeling.
Trying to come into contact, to identify more
closely with his own child.
Laurel: So really observing him and trying
to come closer to understanding him.
Participant: The fact that this was painted
now, in the middle of the middle of the First
World War.
To see one’s child, who may go to this war,
as younger or more innocent.
And he’s wide-eyed with either wonder, terror,
awe.
You can see that Laurel has used her knowledge
of Pierre's age at the time the work was painted
to generate an interpretive question and spark
a new direction in the conversation.
I knew that Pierre was around 16 years old
when this work was made, but knowing this
didn't prevent me from first asking the group
how old they thought the boy in the painting
looked.
We had a fruitful conversation about how old
he might be before I shared what I knew about
how old he actually was.
And, finally, when discussing a work, always
share the name of the artist, the date and
title of the work, and materials used.
While sharing this information is essential,
you may not want to lead with it, as that
could limit participant response.
When you feel ready to bring your conversation
to a close, summarize and synthesize participant
responses.
Here's an example:
Meryl: Now that we’ve had this very fruitful
discussion about Matisse and his family we’re
going to move on to look at another work that
explores another aspect of our theme today.
You can see that the conclusion offers another
opportunity to re-orient participants.
In this case, Meryl did so by linking the
discussion back to the theme and by transitioning
smoothly to the next work.
Your conversation summary is also the time
to ask for final thoughts or opinions from
the group and to share your own broader observations
about the experience.
Thank participants for their contributions
and suggest ways they might continue to explore
the artists, artworks, and ideas that were
discussed.
In general, keep the following ideas in mind
when facilitating a discussion about a work
of art:
Ask a variety of questions in order to prompt
different threads of conversation
Use art historical information purposefully.
It should enhance your conversation, not bog
it down.
And finally provide some initial structure
but allow the conversation to flow.
Be prepared but don't over-direct the experience.
Keeping these ideas in mind will help create
a guided yet open experience that helps participants
to individually and collectively build understandings
about works of art.
ART DISCUSSION
TIPS AND TOOLS
In this section, we'll go over general tips
and tools for successfully facilitating your
discussion.
We'll first share with you some practical
tips for leading a cohesive group conversation
and then discuss some challenging scenarios
that may come up and ways you can address
them.
So, let's begin with general facilitation
strategies.
No matter the group you're working with, it
can sometimes be difficult to balance the
interests, abilities, and personalities of
each of the participants.
Here are some things you can do to foster
an environment of balanced and lively exchange:
The first is to animate the experience yourself.
Think of facilitating a discussion as an opportunity
to be your most performative self, but at
the same time be sure that your level of enthusiasm
does not come across as insincere.
Also, share personal information about yourself
Sharing personal information will make participants
feel more comfortable with you.
It will make the experience feel less formal
or intimidating and more conversational.
During the discussion, address participants
by name and make eye contact.
Don't be afraid to call on people directly
and invite them to comment in a non-threatening
manner.
Also, make eye contact with whoever is speaking
so that they know that you're listening directly
to them.
Always repeat all comments back to the group,
summarizing and synthesizing when necessary.
This strategy helps to validate the person
who is commenting, makes sure those who can't
hear are not at a disadvantage, and helps
to reorient those with short-term memory loss.
So, let's take a look at how this works in
the galleries.
Laurel: What else do you all notice about
this figure on the right hand side?
Participant: Female furniture.
Laurel: Female furniture.
And what makes you say that, Arthur?
Participant: Well the top is definitely female
and the lower parts are sort of a mixture
of female and furniture.
Laurel: Yeah, yeah!
So at the top you can tell that we have the
head of a woman, her shoulders and torso coming
down, and then she sort of blends into this
furniture.
We have the legs that are just down below.
Jordan, were you going to add to that?
Participant: I can’t tell if it’s…well,
the look is that it’s incomplete.
Not painted.
I can’t tell from this angle whether that’s
a deliberate omission or whether it’s painted
to look incomplete but in the coloring, in
the outline, it looks incomplete.
Laurel: Yeah, so there’s something incomplete
about this figure.
And Jordan was saying that he doesn’t know
necessarily whether it was intentional or
not.
Notice that Laurel repeated Arthur's first
comment -- "female furniture" -- to the group
and then asked him to continue.
She then repeated and elaborated on his further
description, supplementing Arthur's observations
with more information that could be helpful
to everyone.
And later, once Jordan gave his description
of this same figure, Laurel repeated just
the key parts back to the group, maintaining
Jordan's wording.
This selected repetition validated Jordan
but also allowed Laurel to choose one idea
to focus on moving forward.
During the discussion provide a visual reference
by pointing to particular parts of the work.
By pointing or gesturing to the work directly,
you quickly and easily direct the group's
looking and keep everyone on the same page.
Similarly, refrain from discussing any object
or image that isn't immediately visually available,
including works that you've discussed prior.
Only reference that which can be seen and
understood by everyone, otherwise you're putting
those with short term memory loss at a disadvantage.
It's okay to bring up an idea that you've
discussed before, but if you do, be sure to
explain it anew so as to maintain group cohesion.
Be mindful not to interrupt participants
Don't cut someone off as they're talking or
try to finish their sentence.
This can be distracting and discourage the
participant from commenting again.
When responding to participants' comments,
validate with sincerity
Go beyond just acknowledging responses or
saying that you find them interesting.
Pick up on something specific within a comment
and respond to that part directly.
Being specific communicates sincere interest.
So let's see an example of this from Laurel's
conversation about The Piano Lesson.
Laurel: Marty, what do you notice?
Marty: I look at the organization as if its
two parts, designated by the long vertical
in the middle.
This part non-human images, except for all
the way in the bottom.
And it projects a certain sleepiness, or things
that are set in their ways.
Whereas the other part is more modern, extreme,
active, and seems to talk to me about the
day.
Laurel: First of all, you notice the structure
of the work, the composition and how it’s
arranged.
And I’m so glad you pointed out this strict
vertical blue line – does everyone see that?
I like how you said that it divides the canvas
into two.
On the left, you have this sort of inanimate
selection of objects; on the right you have
more activity.
Notice how Laurel went beyond just generally
thanking Marty for his comment and instead
expressed appreciation at the fact that he
noticed a particular element of the work,
a central vertical line.
She then invited everyone else to use that
central line to notice the organization of
the scene.
In the same way that it's helpful to share
information about yourself, you should encourage
participants to share their own personal stories.
Even if this temporarily moves the conversation
away from the work at hand, personal narratives
inform individual understanding of the work
and enhance relationships within the group.
Again, let's look at an example of this in
the galleries:
Meryl: Oh, Carole, I happen to know that you
play an instrument.
Did you take lessons your whole life?
Participant: No, I was out of high school
I guess.
Meryl: Oh, you were out of high school when
you started.
Participant: I played in a German Oom-pah
band, in Germany.
Meryl: You played in a German Oom-pah band?
How big was the band?
Participant: Oh, maybe twenty.
Meryl: Twenty people!
My gosh!
Here Meryl takes a bit of information that
she already knows about Carole, that she plays
an instrument, and asks her to share more
about her experiences with the rest of the
group.
Encourage group debate.
When people offer opinions or ideas, invite
other participants to respond to them.
This is an easy way of encouraging socialization
among participants.
It also demonstrates that a variety of interpretations
are possible, valid and as ripe for investigation
as the artwork itself.
Let's see what this can look like:
Laurel: So if this is Matisse’s son.
How do you think he has treated him?
Would you have thought that there was any
kind of personal relationship?
Participant: I keep on looking at the face
and the black outline on his head and ears
and it just gives me the feeling that there’s
a devilish-ness to him.
And I still get the feeling that there is
resistance to the piano lesson.
And maybe that’s the relationship between
father and son.
Laurel: Does anyone else see what Suzy sees?
This idea of resistance to the piano lesson?
Betty, you agree.
Arthur?
Participant: When she said devilish, I kept
thinking of rebellion.
Laurel: Of rebellion.
Participant: Yeah, at the piano.
S19 In this instance Laurel poses a question
to the group regarding how Matisse has painted
his son and Suzy provides her interpretation.
Laurel then asks other participants to respond
to Suzy's comment, looping in Betty and Arthur,
as the conversation continues.
Throughout your discussion, maintain an air
of lightness and humor.
Remember, one of the goals is to create a
fun experience where participants are able
to relax and enjoy themselves.
From the start and throughout, set a tone
that communicates these goals.
Moreover, there can be a level of tension
that comes with lively debate and perhaps
a level of intimidation that comes with discussing
art, especially if it's new to you.
Additionally, the symptoms of Alzheimer's
disease may create moments of awkwardness
or embarrassment.
But by maintaining a light and relaxed tone
and by staying focused on the conversation
and not dwelling on challenging moments, any
instances of embarrassment will be minimized.
But indeed, challenging moments may come up
during your conversation.
We'll now go through a number of situations
we've encountered and suggestions for how
to address them should they arise.
Sometimes a participant may make the same
comment repeatedly due to memory impairments.
If this happens, acknowledge the comment every
time.
Try to use the comment to further the conversation
by connecting it to a new piece of information,
asking a variety of follow up questions, or
by asking participants to respond to it.
So, for instance, imagine that during our
conversation about The Piano Lesson one participant
continues to bring up the reclining figure
in the lower left hand corner.
As this is such a small detail in the work
I wouldn't want to focus on it for too long,
so I need to find ways to honor the participant's
contribution and generate new threads of conversation
each time it comes up.
The first time it comes up, I could ask the
participant, "What draws you to this figure?"
When it comes up again, I could ask the participant
to describe the color of the figure and how
that connects to the other colors that are
used in the work.
The next time, I could ask the participant
to describe the figure's pose, and then we
could compare her pose to the figure in the
upper right hand corner.
And then, if it comes up again I could ask
if the figure seems to be inside or outside
and why.
From there, I could go beyond that figure
and ask what other parts of the work indicate
where this scene might be located.
There are any number of both descriptive and
interpretive questions you can ask to build
on the repeated comment and integrate it into
the larger discussion.
Moreover, you can pose these questions both
to the participant who has made the comment,
but also to the larger group, too, thus drawing
in other participants.
Finally, never ignore the participant.
If necessary you can merely acknowledge the
comment and move on.
Sometimes you can ask a question and you just
don't get a response.
But there are a number of ways to adjust your
mode of inquiry to encourage a quieter group
to participate.
One strategy to get a quiet group talking
is to invite a brief contribution from everyone,
for example asking all participants to share
the first word that comes to mind when looking
at the work at hand.
This can be a great exercise to do as you
start your conversation because it allows
you to get a whole handful of insights that
you can reference later.
Here's an example of Meryl putting this technique
to use:
Meryl: Will everyone please give me one word?
One word to describe the mood of this painting.
Who feels like…Carole, do you have a word
to describe the mood of this painting?
Participant: I’d say calm or peaceful.
Meryl: Calm or peaceful, that’s great.
Anya, would you agree with Carole – calm
or peaceful?
Participant: Yes, the same word.
In that clip, Meryl asks for Carole's word,
and then quickly asks if Anya agrees before
moving onto the rest of the group.
Quickly prompting a brief response -- like
a yes or a no -- demonstrates to group-members
that participating doesn't have to be intimidating;
they don't need to labor over every answer.
Moreover, this activity may make them feel
more comfortable chiming in again later.
Now, in a situation where you have posed a
specific discussion question and no one is
responding, narrow down your question by offering
possible responses to choose from.
For example if a question like "How would
you describe this line?" is met with silence,
follow it up with, "Is it curvy?
Straight?
Short?
Long?
Thick?
Thin?"
Participants may be more likely to select
from options than to generate their own responses.
If this adjustment still does not elicit a
response, you can even re-pose the question
as an either/or or yes/no question, for example
just, "Is this line curvy?"
Again, here's a clip of Meryl narrowing down
a question.
Meryl: Harriet, what is a word you would use
to describe the mood or feeling of this painting?
Participant: I’m having a hard time.
Meryl: A hard time describing it?
Participant: Yes
Meryl: Does it feel energetic?
Participant: A little bit.
Meryl: A little bit energetic.
What feels energetic about it to you?
Another thing you can do to get participants
talking is to pepper the conversation with
questions that touch on personal preference.
Asking something like "Do you like this work?"
is a non-threatening and accessible mode of
inquiry.
Finally, if you are able to draw out someone
who has been reluctant to speak, don't let
this opportunity pass you by!
Continue to engage them by asking a deepening,
follow-up question that prompts elaboration
on their initial response.
Alternatively, you may have a participant
who dominates the conversation.
Address a longwinded comment by patiently
and creatively bringing it to a close.
You can say, "You're presenting so many great
ideas, we can't possibly discuss them all!
I'll repeat the key ones back," at which point
choose one element to focus on and reroute
the conversation.
If a participant continually responds before
everyone else, start to call on other participants
by name instead of posing general questions
to the whole group.
If a participant makes a comment that seems
unrelated to the work or your conversation,
trust that some element of the work or the
experience is allowing them to make a link.
Accept the comment and ask the participant
to elaborate or explain, which may give further
clues as to the connection.
Always be aware of the possibilities of these
connections and don't be dismissive.
For instance, one time I was leading a discussion
of the Piano Lesson, and a participant suggested
that the work looked like a landscape -- specifically,
a forest scene with big groups of tall trees.
I think we'd agree that, while this work does
contain abstract elements that are open to
many interpretations, it is not a representation
of a forest.
But there are a lot of reasons I could see
why she might have made that connection -- the
scale of the work, perhaps, and the big green
patch in the center, suggest an airy openness
you might find in a nature scene.
I noticed that the figure in the lower left
corner is lounging the way you might if you
were outdoors enjoying the shade of a tree,
so I followed up on her comment by drawing
everyone's attention to the pose of that figure,
asking the rest of the group if they agreed
that the figure looked they way you would
if you were reclining and enjoying the outdoors.
In that way, I was able to honor the participant's
comment and also incorporate it into the group
conversation.
If two people are having a side conversation,
allow them to continue as long as they are
not disruptive to the group.
Participants might feel more comfortable talking
one-on-one.
If and when you feel it's appropriate, you
can ask these participants to share their
comments.
You may be in a situation where you have difficulty
understanding a participant's response due
to limited verbal ability, or a participant
may be non-verbal.
Regardless, it is essential to communicate
directly with that participant.
Don't just talk to a care-partner instead.
If you have trouble understanding a participant,
get closer and ask them to repeat.
Try to interpret what they are saying, repeat
it back to them and ask if you've understood
them correctly.
You can also use non-verbal communication
cues, like pointing, to help further clarify
their comments.
In fact you can take advantage of a number
of non-verbal communication cues throughout
your discussion.
If you notice someone smiling, pointing to
the work, shaking or nodding their head, share
these observations with the larger group.
You can pay attention to people's gaze to
see what part of the work attracts them and
integrate that into the conversation.
For example, you can say something like, "I
see Harriet is looking at the figure in the
top left.
Does everyone else see her?
How would you describe her?"
And keep in mind that even if participants
are not responding verbally, it does not mean
that they are not engaged.
Some participants may have varying language
abilities and some people might just be reluctant
to talk in a larger group.
Look for other clues of engagement: are participants
looking at the work or at you?
Do they seem to be taking an interest in what
is going on?
Are they smiling?
These are all good indicators that they are
engaging in their own way.
Of course, these are only a handful of the
challenging situations you could encounter.
New challenges come up every time we teach
and accordingly, we're always learning new
things and improving our practice as educators.
In sum, keep the following in mind:
Take the lead.
You have the ability to inform how participants
interact through your approach and demeanor.
If you remain relaxed and flexible, your participants
will follow suit.
Also, address and encourage each individual
participant, making sure that everyone is
involved in their own way.
Do your best to ensure that you've engaged
with every participant individually at some
point during the conversation.
And finally, maintain the integrity of the
group in order to best foster social exchange.
Find ways to prompt connection between participants
throughout; don't create separate planes of
conversation.
With these approaches in mind, you'll be able
to frame the conversation in a way that minimizes
challenging moments and encourages varied
forms of engagement.